I like to think of myself as an
uncertainty evangelist right like I'm
gonna I'm gonna big like just shouting
it from the rooftops we should all be
embracing uncertainty and in that I
think that you know one of the most
common things that people are saying to
me is isn't uncertainty a barrier to
barrier to success I think there's a
couple of things I think that first of
all this idea you know I don't know or
I'm not sure or it could turn out a lot
of different ways or you know all the
different ways we might express
uncertainty well I believe this things
to be true but I'm like 60% on it I
think they were taught from the earliest
little like as we walk into you know
preschool that you know I'm not sure and
I don't know they're like strings of
dirty words or something I mean last
time you put I don't know on a test what
happened to you pretty sure you got
marked wrong but the thing is that
that's really a shame certainly it's a
much more accurate representation of any
kind of prediction of the future right
if I say to you well I think that we
should implement this business strategy
because here's how it's gonna turn out
well I hope that you're not saying I
know the foreshore it's gonna turn out
that way that's just not an accurate
representation in the world too many
things can intervene there's too much
luck involved in the way that things
turn out even if I know for sure what
the mathematics are right even if I've
got a coin I've examined it I know it's
a fair coin with a heads and a tails so
I know it's gonna land heads or tails
50% of the time right I still don't know
how it's gonna turn out on the next flip
so if you ask me if I flip this coin
what's it gonna land there's one sense
in which I can tell you something with
some certainty I can say well if I've
done my homework I can say well 50% of
the time it will land heads and if you
say to me well no that's not what I want
you to tell me what's it gonna land my
answer has to be I don't know right I
mean that how could I so a it's just
uncertainty as a more accurate
representation of the world and I'd like
to argue that the more accurate your
representation in the world the better
your decisions are and the better you're
gonna propel yourself to success so
that's number one but we're taught that
it's a bad thing I think the other
problem is that I think that we really
confuse
confidence with certainty and there's a
difference you know one of the things
that I used to say in poker when people
would ask me about it they'd say don't
you need to be like super confident to
be a great poker player and I'd say well
it kind of depends on what you mean by
confidence right there's one thing which
would be I would sort of view with
hubris in the face of the game is
thinking that you know much more about
the game than you actually do because
the game is incredibly complicated the
more that you learn about it the more
that you figure out that you don't know
very much about the game so sort of this
there's this expansion of your knowledge
of what you don't know as you go through
and how little you really know that's
even as you're getting better at it it's
sort of on you know your unpeeling it
and there's just more and more layers
underneath it and so I really look at
the game of poker and I say gosh I
really don't know very much about this
I'm really unsure about the strategy I
really don't know how to solve this
problem that's different being than
being confident in the face of your
opponents so those are two very very
separate things and I think we conflate
the two so that what we think is that
being confident is being certain and
here's the problem again it's not an
accurate representation of the world
number one number two it causes you to
be closed-minded and what we always want
to be doing is calibrating and updating
our beliefs because the better the more
accurate our beliefs are the better our
decisions are going to be the better our
predictions about the future that result
from those decisions right because our
decisions are always informed by our
beliefs and our beliefs are really bets
on the future right we're going to
invest some sort of resource that
propels us toward some set of futures
and we're the decision that we make we
think is going to propel us toward the
best possible future if you walk around
certain that what you believe is true
and expressing certainty that what you
believe is true it will close your mind
off to new information because we will
swat it away
confirmation bias motivated reasoning
all of those things are going to cause
us to protect our beliefs which are part
of our identity and we will not be open
to new information it's a really big
difference to be I'm certain of this
belief
I know it's true I'm a hundred percent
and you're thinking about the world is
right or wrong as a post in this little
place you know the middle place if I'm
not sure and now you get new information
and what do you have to do that
disagrees with you it forces you into a
total reversal all of a sudden you have
to say I'm wrong as opposed to well I
believe this thing to be true and I
think I'm you know 60% on it and now you
give me new information well it's a lot
easier to be like well you know what now
I'm like 52 or you told me this thing
that helped you know in you know affirms
what I thought you know what I thought
was a favorite so now I'm like 67 and
that's a lot easier to be a calibrator
because you're not starting from a place
where your identity right is wrapped up
in that belief being certain so that's
number two number three is that
embracing uncertainty is going to help
you be successful because it's going to
invite people to be your collaborators
so here's the thing there's too much
hidden information out there you've only
had the experiences that you have you
only have the hypotheses that you can
come up with you only have the
strategies that you can think of the
tactics you can think of you only
believe what you believe because you're
you so how do we get more information we
go and seek out the opinions of other
people but in order to do that a we have
to be willing to look for it which we
won't do if we already believe we're
certain what's the motivation to go look
for more information if you're certain
and we want to open the door to other
people to tell us what they know to get
their opinions when they have
information that is useful to us that
will really help us update a belief we
want them to be able to share it with us
so when people ask me is an uncertainty
a barrier to success I just turn it on
its head and I say well don't you think
certainty is don't you think that's the
barrier to success
[Music]